NIGHT?
>> I MIGHTDUCHENE DID NOT
SHOOT THAT PUCK AFTER KIRB
IN.
JOSI UNDER PRESSURE  COME THE P.
SPENT TIMEIT OUT.
CLEARING IT AROUND FOR
GRANLUNDOWEVER.
DIDN'T WORK OUT.
ANWAS
LOU AMARILLO, THE PRESIDENT AND
TV TIMEOUT.
HAGEL GOING TO WORK TILL
TRYING TO BUY  IT KNOCKED AWAY.
THERE'S KUBALIK.
KUBALIK TO
GOAL LINE, BUT WE WILL STAY
SCORELESS AFTER  HAAN.
AND THAT STOP NSIDER CHARLIE.
CLUB.
>> I MEAN, AGAIN, YOU'VE BEEN
ABLE TO COACH IN IN T NATIONNG .
LANKINEN THOUGHT HE HAVE
TIMES TONIGHT WHERE THEY HAD A
CHANAN FOR KANE.
A WORK OF GIVE AND GO.
BUT  BEST SHOT OF
NEVER WERE ABLE TO DO THAT LAST
YEARAGAIN.
KUDOS TO HIM.
HE'S ALWAYS DE BY SAROS.
THE SE.
COACH KING DECIDED TO  THE OTHER
FOUR.
HERE IS DeBRINCAT.
TRYING TO GO BACK TOSPECTACULAR.
THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE
WITH DeBRINCAT TO KANE.
SAROS HIM.
GUSTAFSSON FOR DACH.
LOOK DOWN OF HIM.
DUCHENE OPTS IT RED D IT'S KANE,
WIN.
HAWKS WIN!
WHAT A PLAY BY PATRICK KANE TO
KICK